ein mann weiß heute schon was in den
nächsten wochen alles passieren wird
unser offizielles heute-show sommer oder
karierte olaf schubert oder lass uns mal
in dieser letzten sendung gemeinsam
vorausblicken wie wird der g20-gipfel in
hamburg in vier wochen verlaufen mit dem
stargast donald trump of fame monster
freuen
ich glaube hamburg ist gut ich meine
auf der reeperbahn wird trans ehefrau
erst mal nicht erkannt und natürlich ist
trans selber hat ja auch mal so
gebrüstet mit mit seinen sexuellen
ausschweifungen und so und ich glaube da
als hamburg mit der rede man ja
vielleicht wirklich sogar die einzige
deutsche stadt
diese sexuelle wucht irgendwie schlucken
kann aufnehmen kann
hier gibt's natürlich erstmal nicht nur
angenehm für in den mutterschutz
rechtfertigen öffnet das soll das klima
abkommen gekündigt hat da muss man ein
tramp aber auch verstehen ich meine alte
männer hans gerne warm aber abgesehen
davon wird für ihn glaube ich wird
interessant g20 der lernt so viele neue
länder gehen ich meine
acht kinder ja schon also ich würde fünf
kantone selber drei hatten seine berater
und und hamburg da kennt das ja auch auf
weitere hendrix das liegt gleich neben
kritik natürlich seine prognose geht im
deutschen wahlkampf weiter kommt dann
noch mal ein hauch von spannung rein
oder was müssen die lotsen was müsste
die spd machen und da noch mal spannung
rein zu bringen ist spannend also wenn
die spd weiterhin so straff abbaut dann
schalten sie natürlich nicht es gibt ja
immer welche die dann die spd trotzdem
noch wählen glaube ich gar nicht nur aus
gewohnheit mehr so aus mitleid aber wenn
man die so kurz streichelt irgendwie die
spd führte dieser sollte auch
entwürdigend also dann
ich denke dann lieber meinen richtigen
outfit ins gesicht wir haben alle wieder
ihren frieden ich meine in der natur
sicher auch so ne bei der elefantenherde
dass der kranke alte der wird
weggeschoben damit den wald geht und ab
spd natürlich nie machen sie wird noch
gebraucht im bundestag als raumteiler
oder fertig und die gute alte tante spd
vor allem wichtig ist immer so wenn drei
frauen ausgehen
dabei geht nicht so mein mann sagt klar
sein muss auch geben
damit sich die anderen beiden bässe
fühlen genau und das ja und deshalb ist
die spd bei allen parteien als
koalitionspartner so beliebt wie
kontrastreiche die union die union setzt
weiter konsequent auf das thema
sicherheit wird sprach ich schon drüber
verbrechensbekämpfung also die ängste
der deutschen ist das die richtige
strategie
also man muss die ängste natürlich
geschickt einsetzt also ich habe meine
frau zumindest eingeredet dass unsere
attraktiver nachbar dass er angeblich
afghanischen migrationshintergrund und
verdient ist bei mir wieder viele
anschmiegsamer also der typische
möglichkeit spanier aber das ist sein
problem mit der so aussieht also unter
schön an den ängsten ist ja es gibt so
viele dass man kann sich jeden tag im
internet eine neue explosion
antwort das wirklich angst vor strahlung
jetzt auch vorfeld unter deutschen
apotheken gefälschte medikamente neu
gekaufte betablocker uns in ghana blog
auch grün oder jahrelang irgendwelche
tabletten verständigt aus bis hin zu
ziehen und dann werden wir wenn wir
voraus blicken auf diesem sommer gibt es
natürlich den anhaltenden zoff mit
erdogan und der türkei über das
weitergehen ich bewerte ja erdogan und
trank immer auch ein bisschen nach dem
entertainment faktor und da hat ja
erdogan nicht gekommen
muss jetzt liefern also also er kann ja
im sommer jetzt punkten sage ich mal
wenn die todesstrafe eingeführt oder
wenigstens erstmal für die frau soll
versuchsweise
und dann muss natürlich auch im land
aufräumen und ihn kommt jetzt so passt
es kommen nur noch wenig urlaub in die
türkei das singen
viele hotels kann er dann gleich als
gefängnis muss aber natürlich vor
ordentlichen werten vorher einschnitt
ich war mal so kann man die anbieter
viele deutsche sind tatsächlich sehr
verunsichert in diesem jahr wo soll man
wo kann man noch urlaub machen wo laut
befreundet ist wenn jetzt guck mal wie
alle einen gebräunten tiefenentspannt
also wenn ich höre noch arbeiten gehen
ich meine ich ziehe auch durch ich fahre
dreimal im jahr für meine diesen aber
ansonsten geht wirklich tageslicht
[Applaus]